[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
harry cole and pippa crea a very good
evening to you pleased to say that they
will both be here with us until just
before midnight
so let's take a look at what's on
tomorrow's front pages and escape from
mario poll is the headline in the metro
which carries an account of two
journalists escaping from the besieged
ukrainian city after they were placed on
what the paper calls a kremlin hit list
for revealing vladimir putin's war
crimes to the world
the times also focuses on mario paul
saying that the russian leader is
threatening civilians to try to break
their spirit
the eye reports from kerson where
russian troops opened fire on unarmed
people staging a peaceful protest they
say
the telegraph has a picture of what it
believes is vladimir putin's half a
billion pound super yacht and says it
could be seized by authorities in italy
as part of sanctions against russia
well the guardian reveals what it says
are billions of dollars of assets around
the world linked to russians with
alleged ties to mr putin
the daily mail reports that the man on
trial for the murder of mp sir david
amos had allegedly staked out other mps
and even cabinet ministers as possible
targets
the financial times reports that the
head of the u.s federal reserve is
looking at tightening monetary policy
including putting up interest rates in a
bid to curb rising inflation
the express is worried about finances
nearer to home and is urging the
chancellor to raise pensions in
wednesday's spring statement
while the star has news that football
pundit chris camara is quitting live tv
work
and a reminder by scanning the qr code
that you can see on screen during the
program you can check out all the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
but now let's uh take a look at some of
them and chat through them with the
political editor of the sun harry cole
and political editor of the daily mirror
pippa carrera good to see you this
evening you too
so let's get stuck into the papers and
there's a bit of a range of different
stories actually on the front pages
aren't there harry you've picked out the
telegraph first of all it's that second
story here looking ahead to the spring
statement on wednesday
a lot of speculation about how rishi
sunak might tackle the cost of living
crisis and so what's the take the
telegraph has
so this was meant to be uh but she's you
know sort of uh steady as she goes um
you know i'm fixing the finances after
after the pandemic and you know we're
getting back to normal this isn't to be
a budget we're going to get out of the
cycle of having two budgets every year
and instead this is because it could be
a little update about what the what the
finances are looking like and some minor
tinkering on the edges that's obviously
been blown out of the water by the
situation in ukraine the surging oil
price the surging cost of energy bills
fuel
food inflation and um once again this
chancellor who you know remember his
first budget he gave in in march 2020
where he always had to give another one
10 days later just as uh as kobet first
started ripping through through britain
and again he's sort of having seen all
of his um well-laid plans sort of go up
in smoke quite literally um with with us
with this spring statement and they're
very keen to say it's not a budget it's
not a budget it's not a budget but it's
beginning to sound like actually there
could be some quite serious uh fiscal um
moves um especially on tax policy
uh on on wednesday and the telegraph are
honing in on not getting rid of
necessarily the national insurance hike
to pay for increased nhs funding as lots
of tory mps some of them in the cabinet
as the telegraph point out tomorrow
would like to happen uh but actually how
can you mitigate the effects of that of
that tax rise 1.25 percent on on on
workers and another 1.25 percent on
their employers and it looks like there
could be some movements with the
national insurance threshold which comes
in at about ten thousand just under ten
thousand pounds now if that was moved up
to say eleven thousand pounds or twelve
thousand pounds you might start to see
some of the hardest pressed and lowest
paid workers excluded from this tax rise
and it does feel to me uh a little bit
like the moon music is that's where it's
heading uh would you agree with that
pippa because this has been criticized
this national insurance rise by various
politicians and some business leaders as
well haven't they
not least because of the timing of it
and yet we did have the chancellor and
boris johnson recommitting to it just a
matter of weeks ago
yes i mean it's been this push from uh
from conservatives not just about
benchers but also some ministers
including those in cabinet to delay
the national insurance rise it's
obviously going up for for uh the main
rate for employees from 12 12 to 13.5 to
that 1.5 percentage point increase which
could be quite substantial and harry
says i think what we're most likely to
see is a sort of targeted support
there's been calls across the board for
things like a cut in fuel duty um for
the like i say for the delay in the
national insurance rise
um and various other measures which the
government believes are not targeted
enough if you look at the support which
they've given so far to help with the
costly living crisis and of course this
predates the ukraine war and the
knock-on impact that's had on on energy
prices global global gas and oil prices
but the but initially um with cost of
living crisis on the horizon the
government announced a package of
support which was targeted through
um both refunds through energy suppliers
to households of about 200 pounds and
also support through council tax and the
idea of doing it that way rather than
sort of you know um
more sort of headline measures which
would affect everybody is that the
support is targeted at those that are
worst affected because it is the poor
who are who overwhelmingly affected by
all of this some families will pay
perhaps a quarter of their monthly
income on energy bills and with those
set to go up in some cases to double
that's obviously a massive blow and much
less sustainable for them than it is for
wealthier families so i think any
support you'll see whether it is raising
threshold as harry says or any other
measures possibly an extension of some
of the um
some of the schemes which already in
place
are likely to be targeted at the least
off because they're going to be the
worst hit by all of this okay and a
quick word on the sun's coverage your
papers coverage a harry we've got page
two here that the main headline on that
page is fuel prices are hurting i get it
because there's obviously a call to
tackle of fuel duty but i know that
you've also focused on the issue of of
debt haven't you and uh
the soaring yeah so the the problem the
the problem that british city has is
that he'll be probably handed in the
next wall right about now actually i
suspect for the next 24 hours the the
forecast for the for the coming year and
um also tomorrow we're going to get
public sector borrowing figures and if
you top that up just the level of
interest payments the government are
paying this year on that massive coveted
debt that that's now being driven up by
by uh you know the price price
volatility and various other issues on
the global markets means that actually
for 21.22 the government is going to end
up with paying taxpayers good enough
paying more than 50 billion pounds just
on the interest on the debt and that's
more than 45 billion pounds that we
spend on schools so i think there'll be
a bit of a desperate plea from the
chancellor just keep all of this in
perspective and go yes look i want to
help but at the same time we do have to
keep that bet down and get the deficit
down because you know we are wasting
essentially billions of pounds that
could go on public services literally
going on interest payments okay we're
going to take a quick break there um
lots more to talk about after the break
though so don't go anywhere including uh
russian troops turn on peaceful
ukrainian protesters in the occupied
city of kessom that's according to the
eye we'll talk about that in just a
moment
[Music]
you're watching the press preview with
me tonight is the political editor of
the son harry cole and political editor
of the daily mirror pippa crera and
people we're returning to the front page
of the daily telegraph because there's
an article at the bottom
that says partygate accused may deny
charges say says met and there was news
today that the met police was going to
start interviewing people in connection
with these allegations of of parties in
downing street and also widen its
investigation
yes and this is the first we've heard
from the met for some weeks on operation
hillman which of course is their
investigation into the
the uh allegations of parties held in
downing street and across whitehall um
during lockdown and what they met
announced today in the statement was
that they would be
holding face-to-face interviews having
up until this point focused on providing
on um uh getting uh questionnaires from
uh from some of those individuals
involved uh and that's so that raises
obviously the prospect of the prime
minister himself his wife carrie and
some of their senior aides being
interviewed under caution face to face
which would be the first time of course
the prime minister that that has
happened to her prime minister um and
the met also revealed that they've
already sent out more than a hundred
of these questionnaires which is higher
than we previously thought
and they explained that this is because
as they had questionnaires coming in
other individuals were implicated and
then they had to try and approach them
and sort of cross-reference the stories
if you like
um but they also point out that no fixed
penalty notices have been issued thus
far now what's not clear from the
statement is whether that is because
they are still going through that
process of cross-referencing all those
different bits of information all those
bits of evidence they also have 300
photos and lots of documents at their at
their disposal to look into or whether
that's because none of those have
actually met the threshold thus far and
they made clear that should they meet
the threshold they will impose fines and
number 10 has told us that they'll let
us know if the prime minister or whether
prime minister is interviewed or indeed
if he's issued with a fine himself and
it's our understanding this evening that
he hasn't yet been approached by the met
for a face-to-face interview but i think
we're all anticipating that coming in
the in the days and weeks ahead well yes
and harry how worried do you think the
prime minister will be about this news
of a widening investigation and
interviews starting to take place we saw
jacob rees-mogg dismissing concern about
so-called party gay didn't we he said it
was fluff and fundamentally trivial but
but do you think there will be worries
at number 10
i think it's a little bit of wishful
thinking there from jacob's mob then you
know when this uh you know when the met
do eventually come back with an answer
one way or another there's going to be a
lot of shouting either way
regardless of what the mets say so i
think it's a uh a row delayed rather
than a row or subdued um i thought the
statement by the met was a bit weird
actually today it was it was very long
and didn't really say very much and in
it it kept stressing that these anyone
being interviewed was going to be
interviewed as a witness
rather than a suspect and i can't get my
head around how anyone who
is going to be interviewed for attending
an event
uh could be interviewed as a witness
rather than being a suspect unless
perhaps they're talking about some of
the police people
on duty in downing street at the time
perhaps security guards because anyone
actually
who is
under investigation can't really be
interviewed as a witness they have to be
interviewed as a suspect so it struck me
as a bit of a
a statement that was sort of you know
this has died down for a few weeks the
met you know rumbling on spending lots
of money on this investigation it felt
like they sort of needed to say
something and have dressed up a lot more
than they actually have to report back
uh into the into the statement and it
almost leaves more questions than it
answers and um
on the widening thing
oh i just said very briefly in fact i'm
going to have to end it there but i
think we're going to revisit this
subject in the 11 o'clock hour and harry
and paper for the moment thanks very
much indeed